(sirens wailing)
- [Interviewer] All
right, what is your name?
- [Amanda] Amanda Reinhardt.
- [Interviewer] Amanda?
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And
where'd ya grow up Amanda?
- [Amanda] LA.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about your family,
did you grow up with both of your parents?
- I grew up with my auntie and uncle,
and they took me in cause
I lived with my dad,
he turned out to be a
molester, so his wife left him.
So now I live in Downtown
LA as a prostitute,
and I'm a crack head.
- [Interviewer] You do crack?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And where
do you stay, here in a tent?
- No, I just walk the
streets all night and day.
- [Interviewer] Oh you do?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And--
- I'm a clone.
(laughs)
- [Interviewer] Did I already talk to you?
- No.
- [Interviewer] You sure
I haven't talked to you?
I think I have.
- No.
No.
- [Interviewer] So who
do you stay with now?
- I stay with my father,
he turned out to be a molester
so I just walk the street day and night,
prostituting and smoking.
Downtown LA.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
you look very different,
I think I spoke to you before.
Have you finished school?
How much school have --
- I went to Seaside.
I got accepted to ELP,
a special program, so.
I dropped out after two years.
- [Interviewer] You
dropped out from where?
- Seaside.
- [Interviewer] College?
So you went to two years of college?
And do you have any contact
with your family at all,
your mom or sisters or brothers?
- No, my mom got killed in a fire,
so she wasn't in my life anyway,
but I lied a whole lot of people,
tellin' them that she was in my life,
you know, just to seem normal, so.
But my mom got killed recently in a fire.
- [Interviewer] And how old are you now?
- 23.
- [Interviewer] 23.
And you got a black eye.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] How'd you get a black eye?
- A date.
I asked him to go get some more crack
and he just took off on me.
I'm a clone so people control me,
so they use technology to
orthodox him to beat me up,
'cause they get frustrated
'cause I'm comfortable,
when I get comfortable.
- [Interviewer] Do you
have any family at all,
any aunts, uncles?
- Yeah my dad, but he turned
out to be a molester, so--
- [Interviewer] So just
your dad, is all you have?
- Yeah.
I don't have no support.
- [Interviewer] You have no support?
- No.
- [Interviewer] And the only money
you get is from guys on the street?
- Right.
- [Interviewer] Oh boy.
- Or I ask for dollars and change
from the liquor store around here.
- [Interviewer] Wow.
- [Amanda] But I do wanna
say, it's kinda random,
you did an interview me before,
but I wanna tell my country,
thank you so much for,
you know what I'm sayin',
the whole downtown thing.
I'm sorry for not cleanin'
myself up and really tryin',
but, you know what I'm sayin', thank you.
- [Interviewer] How long
have you done crack?
- [Amanda] I only did crack
like a year and a half?
- [Interviewer] Only a year and a half?
- [Amanda] Yeah.
- You were in college just a
few years ago though, right?
- [Amanda] Yeah, like crack
is the best thing for me.
It really lifts my heart and it's like,
you know what I'm sayin',
it's my everything.
- [Interviewer] Crack is your everything?
- [Amanda] Yeah.
People lean on drugs,
you know what I'm sayin'?
- [Interviewer] Who are
you hanging with now,
the gentleman, that is.
- [Amanda] I just hang by myself,
or with somebody that has crack.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so
he has crack for you?
- [Amanda] Yeah, I
search for crack all day,
I crave crack.
- [Interviewer] And sometimes
the guys beat you up.
- [Amanda] Yep, he beat me up.
- [Interviewer] Who beat you up?
- [Amanda] This Mexican, I'm a clone,
so I'm bein' controlled.
So the people that
control me get frustrated
when I'm comfortable, so they
orthodox him with technology
or they control other
people to beat me up.
So, it was hard.
- [Interviewer] Amanda, there is a couple
of mental health places,
they're are right in
the neighborhood here.
Would you mind, maybe, going over there?
- Yeah I been to the mental
home a couple of times,
but I get frustrated and there's no drugs,
you know what I'm sayin'?
- [Interviewer] And what do you do?
- I just get frustrated
there, there's no drugs.
- [Interviewer] And you leave?
- No, you know what I'm sayin',
like, two or three days.
I stay two or three days.
- [Interviewer] And then you leave?
- Yeah.
I'm a clone, so I'm also
hurting someone else,
'cause they use animals to,
you know, that's part of the technology
they use to clone you.
So I'm hurting someone else.
So I die today or tomorrow.
So you really just gotta stay
productive in this country,
make sure you have a job,
make sure that everything's
together, you have a purpose,
you're always reachin' for something,
because they'll kill y'all here,
you know what I'm sayin?
I have a storyline in my head,
you know what I'm sayin',
'cause my country put
a storyline in my head,
so in that storyline,
they say that in America,
you know what I'm sayin',
everybody gets murdered,
so just live life to the fullest,
I don't know how true that
is, but I know I'm a clone,
so, you know what I'm
sayin', that's what's up.
- [Interviewer] Okay so Amanda,
if I wanted to walk you over
to one of those mental health
facilities here, that's good?
- No, I'm gonna get
killed today or tomorrow,
so I wanna be out and
doin', you know, crack,
and just bein' out.
So that's it.
(laughs)
But I'm glad I got to make
a second video with you,
so I can tell my country
thank you so much,
and, you know, to person that writes
my thoughts might tell you
I had some ungrateful times,
but, you know what I'm
sayin' I'm very thankful.
I'm so sorry about
everybody dyin' and stuff,
I didn't know, but when
I heard about them,
you know what I'm sayin', everybody,
you know what I'm sayin',
I can't change things.
- [Interviewer] Alright Amanda,
I'm gonna see if I can --
- [Amanda] Thank you, thank you America.
- [Interviewer] Thank you.